acha speakers Levent himself from
Waterloo he's been here for the whole
semester and he'll tell us about primal
dual algorithms for hyperbolic
programming blocks
thank you very much Byrne it's a great
pleasure to be here I thank the
organizers for this special semester and
for this workshop it has been a
wonderful wonderful productive semester
so far and today I'll talk about joint
work with Levon Vanderburgh from UCLA
and one of the nice things about talking
about this work here first is that it
actually started here when there was
another special semester of activity is
an optimization about air and a half ago
and I listened to leave and give a talk
early in the semester that was the
second time I heard that talk and that
was something that I wanted to talk to
him about the first time I saw the talk
so and then after the second time I
couldn't resist
and then sometimes some exciting
exciting results and sued and I like to
share it with you but I resisted my
usual interior point presentation where
where I prepare 120 slides and bombard
you like a ruptured fire hose with
notation and other things so that at
least you know we can have this
situation where there is this questions
by boarding so that people can have time
to think about questions so one of the
fortunate things for me is that James
already started with some notation which
is actually very useful the same
notation I've been using in my notes
which I hope I think is the same
notation that Jumeirah guy will use in
the next talk because it's jim's
notation so so we'll have some notion of
continuity here let's see if we can find
more smoothness okay so so we're gonna
we're gonna have we're gonna start with
polynomials and and variables so let P
be homogeneous homogeneous polynomial
degree let's call it theta so I banned
variables degrees theta such that P is
hyperbolic in Direction e and this is
precisely to the point of PE being
positive the same definition I mean the
James used okay so I mean that PE is
positive and when you look at the scalar
polynomial P X plus X minus lambda e all
the theta roots are real okay and then
we can define a map lambda from RN to R
theta such that I'm gonna write lambda X
is lambda 1 X lambda 2 X lambda theta X
and these are ordered on the one of X's
if you like greater or equal to lambda 2
greater equal to lambda theta X and what
are these lambdas well these are the
roots so so so lambda eyes are the roots
of P X minus lambda e right so again we
were just refreshing our memories about
how James define things and then he also
defined this hyperbola city cone and as
I warned you about me
bombarding you with lots of notation one
way to avoid that is to abuse notation
so we already saw that hyperbola city
cone depends on P as well as E
at least the first time you define it
but certainly depends on P so but the
thing is there's always gonna be P any P
you like like this so I'm not gonna
write P and I'm not gonna write E and if
you're worried about E in almost all the
applications I want you to think about
the example of example of the positive
semi-definite cone intersected with an
arbitrary linear subspace and then your
polynomial is the determinant and your a
is I the identity alright and then these
are the eigenvalues okay so so this cone
run away from me is the set of all X's
in RN such that all the eigenvalues are
non-negative as a vector every entry of
that lambda of X is non-negative and the
the if you want to look at the interior
of this cone then the the interior we
are going to denote by double plus and
that will be precisely everything in
this cone such that lambda theta is
positive or all of them are positive
because done the theta is the minimum of
all of them okay so so this was the same
kind of setup so now we're going to move
to these hyperbolic optimization
problems so we're gonna say okay so let
a some linear map from RN to R M so this
is linear and some B that's in RM and
some see that's Dhahran be given so this
is our data a triple one is the linear
map and two others are elements of RM n
RN and then we have an optimization
problem which is to find the infimum
of CX subject to ax equals B and X is in
the hyper ballistic on and in convex
optimization we always have at least one
dual problem that's associated with
every given convex optimization problem
in this case I'll pick the conic dual so
the dual problem is defined so this is a
definition is the problem of maximizing
this linear form with dual variables y
subject to a star y plus s equals C so a
star is like a transpose it's the
adjoint of this linear transformation
and s must be in the cone that is dual
to our hyperbola stick-on so this is the
kind of animal we don't know as much
about we would like to know more about
but for purposes of today's talk you'll
see that we know enough so if
interesting algorithms so notice that so
I'm not going to use the definition
notation because I'm operating with the
general definition of a dual of a convex
cone that's why I'm writing as an
equality so so this is the set of all
this is in RN such that s X is
non-negative for all X in the hyperbola
stick-on I'm using capital lambda plus
for diaper ballistic on and you see the
beautiful choice of notation by Reiniger
these are the small numbers alright so
is the is the dual problem clear defined
by the same data and the dual cone is
defined implicitly like this ok so
typically an interior point methods at
least the theoretical ones we also
assume that some X 0 there is in the
interior of the hyperbola stick on and
some s 0 that is in the interior of the
interior of the duquan are given to us
their starting points such that such
that they are feasible so ax 0 is equal
to B and a star y 0 plus a 0 is equal to
C now you might say you didn't define y
0 what's Y 0 well if you give me n is 0
that is in the interior of the dual cone
such that it satisfies this equality for
some why I mean by y 0 such a way so
again I'm defining it implicitly and in
particular if a is surjective then that
Y is unique right and you may assume a
surjective rights because of a system of
linear equations here a is not
surjective you just pray process this
and you will find redundant equations or
you'll find a contradiction to solve the
beauty of this that's one way to solve I
proposed upon optimization problems ok
not always successful so so be if you
are ok with the setup and these are
really without loss of generality so one
of the one of the nice things about this
kind of assumption even though it's a
little bit too strong it guarantees that
both problems attain their optimal
values and those optimal values are
equal to each other so that's nice and
then we can go on and try to try to
solve these things and so one of the yes
very good the question is you're
assuming some kind of strict feasibility
are not assuming any compactness no I'm
not assuming any compactness but his
suspicion is right there's some
compactness that underlies things so
what happens is that the the set of
optimal solutions actually will be
compact in many cases and you can you
can you can use that
okay any any other questions right so
this is an important moment in the
algorithms so we're going to define a
function and this function is going to
be a function from RN to extended wheels
so we will extend the real line
tiny bit at one end will allow plus
infinity this is something that we do in
convex optimization analysis that's
extremely nice and useful and what is
the function well this is something that
we also saw already in James's talk this
is minus log P of X if X is in the
interior of the cyber ballistic on and
it's plus infinity otherwise so this is
this is the function and then this
function is a lot of nice properties so
maybe I should start from the nice
properties now before before we forget
so properties of f
we need slash shoes so so first property
is that the domain of this function is
the interior diaper ballistic on so it's
a closed convex function in the so
closed and convex function and the
domain of F where it's finite is the is
the interior of the hyperbola stick on
so it's there so you might say well
that's that's a weird way to say I
haven't seen convex analysis yet I am in
boarding class a or boarding class one
and the world tell me tell me
differently so then I would say well
this is a convex function and that
definition you should know and please
look it up if you don't and it has the
property that if you take any sequence
in the interior of the whole hyperbola
stick on that converges to a boundary
point the values of the function f tag
to plus infinity and you see from these
definitions that on the boundary of the
I proposed the cone at least one of the
eigen values namely the smallest one is
zero and then you see that this indeed
tends to plus infinity so it has got
this nice barrier property okay so this
is a this is a kind of thing the three-d
minimum requirements the interior point
methods to have your function formulate
your set so the second property I want
is theta logarithmic homogeneity this is
really makes the mathematics nice there
are ways to avoiding it but then I have
to replace it with something else and
really a simple simple property and here
behavior automatically my polynomial is
degree theta so homogeneous polynomials
therefore if you look at the minus
logarithm of say P of T times X this is
same as T to the theta times P of X
and you see that a term of minus theta
Lochte will come out so that is the
definition of theta logarithmic
homogeneous but in terms of polynomials
it just means that by homogeneous
polynomial here with dignity so every
monomial if you write this vector
monomial basis it's all degree theta so
it's really trivial again what is the
third one I saved the best for last
what is this this is this function I'm
gonna write it like like this and then
I'm gonna write it like this so first of
all before I say the property what I'm
writing is that I'm looking at the first
derivative of my function so I should
really be looking at at W that's in the
integral diaper booty cone and I am
taking the scalar product with some X
okay so what I'm gonna say that this is
calm X for all X and the hyperbola stick
on so now what I am saying is that I'm
thinking about this as a function of W
okay so I'm thinking of this function as
a function that takes W to this and W is
a function this domain is the interior
of the hyperbola stick on okay so this
is it so these are the three properties
that underline the most sort of general
algorithms that we have in this
framework in joint work with levon
Vanderburgh and then we have some sort
of special algorithms that that will
have more property that will move
sparsity but but this is it so those of
you are experts you probably expect me
to do something about South concordant
barriers I'm not gonna do it do you
already know why because these are
enough these are enough and in fact
strong
in some sense than self concordance
because for instance if you read Reina
guards beautiful book South concordant
barriers you'll see it he operates with
this deacon ellipsoid condition these
conditions essentially guaranteed deacon
ellipsoid like condition that's the
variance of the hessian over the
interior of the feasible region for
essentially a large larger convex set
and the deacon ellipsoid so in that
sense these are actually stronger and
then what is this this convexity of this
thing I mean this animal is not foreign
to us James is nodding his head that
because he's nice to me he's also nice
to me but but the reason his none is
because he used this precisely in his
slides right he hid this quantity twice
alright so so maybe have seen that
animal it's a se key thing and I me also
know actually that this is a bijection
it gives the by ejection between the
integral primal and you'll cons but PO
makes you of this is this is important
so maybe I should say a little bit more
since I said that's important so first
of all that conditioning in this sort of
global setting was first used as far as
I know by Nesterov and Todd and in many
ways we can look at their work from 97
and 98 as starting with just these
axioms not only for the primal cone but
also for the dual cone so what it means
is that you get teach to automatically
somehow for the fan shell sort of the
dual barriers but this one you have to
assume for the dual barrier so so if you
do that then you really have Nesterov
taught setup so you could actually do
all of their theorems starting with this
for both primal and dual barriers so
that's that's beautiful so one of the
observation one of the results due to
glare in 1997 was that one of those
sides you could generalize to all
hyperbolic
polynomials in the sense that it applies
to I proposed the cones and this this
function okay so let me say a little bit
more about this condition this condition
is equal
to what we call negative curvature so
so negative curvature you can you can
you can write this in terms of the third
derivative
so it tells you that venue when you take
the third derivative at any interior
point of your hyper ballistic cone and
then now there's a three linear
transformation you evaluate one of the
arguments at any point inside the high
probabilistic cone then that gives you a
symmetric bilinear form that's symmetric
bilinear form is negative semi definite
okay so so that's that's that's that's
another equivalent characterization of
this but maybe burned mention geometry
we have to do more geometry this is too
much analytics all right oh so this is
the third derivative of f they are very
good so if I so the question is isn't
this third derivative of F a three
tensor it's a three linear form yes so I
haven't defined the notation so I have
to explain so if I wanted to evaluate
this third derivative I would need three
directions from RN h 1 H 2 H 3 and I
would get a scalar from the stencil what
I am doing here is that I'm evaluating
it only along one direction so then I'm
getting it as a result that answer
essentially right so I'm getting it I'm
getting this I'm getting a bilinear form
it's a trillionaire form I am putting
only one element and if you like to be
more formal that's actually a good point
see I said when I said I'm gonna abuse
the notation I wasn't kidding Pablo is
keeping me straight so what I mean is
this if you like so there are two dots
there that I am not doing anything to so
now I'm thinking of this as a bilinear
form and systematic bilinear form it's
negative semi definite great and but
then you notice that this guy is the
Hessian of this guy no it's negation of
the Hessian of that guy
if your function is three times going to
use differentiable it's indeed the same
condition and but but as I said geometry
so what does it say about geometry
coolant lis and this is perhaps the
cleanest geometric condition when you
look at now the Hessian at any interior
point of the hyperbola stick on as a
linear map you fix the W in the interior
and think about there's a linear map
that map's the primal space to the dual
space and what it does is when you apply
to the prime of hyperbola stick on this
gives you a convex cone and that convex
cone is contained in the dual of the
hyperbola stick on so this a purely
geometric property that's supposed to
hold for every W in the interior of the
I propose the cone is a coolant rating
negative curvature which is a coolant T
to having this function is a convex
function is that is that okay yes right
very good question so Pablo says I said
something about these things implying
self concordance and actually being
stronger and he wants more explanation
so self concordance we typically have
this other condition that says that the
third derivative is bounded by the
second derivative with the right degree
of homogeneity so that has the word self
concordance it tells you that the growth
of the Hessian is regulated by its own
derivative so so so so if the Hessian is
small as an operator then the changes in
it will be expected to be small because
the third derivative is bounded by the
Hessian so that that's the condition
that's maybe not the nice nicest way of
writing it since we're talking about the
s
then you could say okay I'm sitting at
an interior point X I wanna pick a
direction H and I want to see how the
Hessian changes along this direction so
a : t we can say that the change is
bounded so that is so this condition
leads to that change being bounded in a
bigger bigger set and I'm gonna do a
Mickey Mouse picture to explain it
better so for that I'm going to define
define two things so so given given H in
RN and okay maybe I should make a
general statement first in interior
point methods and many first order
methods we design analyze and implement
algorithms based on
local metrics so so each function like
this induces a local metric with its
Hessian at that point so and it relates
to geometry so for all H n RN we can
define this local norm which speak to
some W let me just take the square so I
avoid the square root on the other side
so this is defined to be f double-prime
wh h ok so so then what we're what we
are saying is that when you look at the
unit ball which speak to this norm
it's an ellipsoid and the shape and size
of the ellipsoid is determined by the
Hessian
so this is one definition and there's
another definition that we should have
this is the Minkowski function again
measuring how how H is so want me to
define this is as taking the so there
are many ways of writing it this is what
I like X minus th sorry W minus th W
minus th
so you're sitting at a point W and
you're looking at a direction H and
you're trying to find what is the
largest step I can take from W in the
direction of a minus H so that I stay in
the car okay and smaller the Sigma the
larger the step you can take with
respect to H so these two things
geometrically are rather are very
important so over here no no no so this
is a this is a positive definite
positive definite form right because so
this is not this is this is not the
gradient of this guy this is just the
Hessian of the Hessian of the barrier so
this is this is indeed always positive
and it has to be positive definite for
you to define a norm so so let me
describe some of the geometry and boy
okay so so so suppose that I do what
James suggested if you remember he
looked at these cones and then he took
these hyper planes that were orthogonal
to the direction of hyperbola see you
don't have to quite take the orthogonal
ones you can take any interior point
from the dual cone and you let that kind
of a geometry and that's what I want to
look at I'm slicing the cone in in
certain way so that say maybe I'm
looking at a point W maybe it's X and
then I'm looking at I am looking at this
function this is the minkowski function
with Paul W and I am looking at what's
the largest step I can take in this
direction what's the largest step I can
take in this direction and so on I'm
doing this and then from this idea when
I define another norm I am going to
define a cone norm with respect to the
with respect to the hyperbola stick-on
and the point W is the maximum of this
Minkowski function and also the same
function for the other direction so what
does this what does this do so what this
does is that it creates the largest
largest centrally symmetric set that is
contained in my cone that's centered at
W so so so so this norm induces a ball
or the ball in this is a norm either way
right and the underlying ball is the
compact convex set which is the largest
centrally symmetric convex set you can
put in the cone that's centered at W so
this is in some sense the best local
approximation to your set inner best
inner local approximation that's
symmetric right so what is it about the
other norm induced by the Hessian so the
unit ball for that guy what does it look
like in this Mickey Mouse picture in the
Mickey Mouse picture or any other Mickey
Mouse picture it's always contained in
the interior of of your cone or in
general if you take the slice with the
affine subspace it's contained in your
feasible region so the usual self
concordance gives you this deacon
ellipsoid it's this blue ellipsoid and
it's always in the interior and you can
use it to design analyze algorithms and
they're typically going to be what we
call short step algorithms whereas this
convexity of that gradient function or
the negative curvature equivalent the or
this beautiful geometric condition that
the Hessian of this this function Maps
the hyperbola cone into the dual cone
all the time
guarantees that you could work with this
largest centrally symmetric convex set
as
approximation is the geometry sort of
vaguely clear so they're whole bunch of
norms that are going around and in fact
I'm not going to be able to analyze the
algorithms theoretically in this talk
but as you can imagine that our operator
norms induced by this norm as well as
this norm and in fact we can use the
operator norms induced by this this norm
in Port answers that come from Hessians
or the third derivatives and we can
bound things in their natural domain
with with these things okay so so the
general ideas I think are ok but but now
I need to say a little bit more I'm
gonna maybe do it from here so James
said in optimization we design we
propose a class of optimization problems
a family and I will feel jealous if I
don't do it
so let's do a family of optimization
problems let me be positive scalar value
and then define define the following
family of problems let's call it P mu
which is to find the infimum of 1 over
mu c x plus f of X subject to ax equals
B so since the domain of f is the
interior of the hyperbola stick-on i can
just ignore that difficult constraint
when I do this minimization because this
function is plus infinity everywhere
else and I already know that there are
solutions X 0 that are that are feasible
so under these assumptions of Xu and
esther existing and a being surjective
this problem has a unique solution
unique solution for every positive meal
unique solution X mu s mu and Y mu for
every mu that's positive and that
solution is characterized by ax equals B
X is in the interior of the hyperbola
stick on a star y plus s is equal to C
and s is equal to minus mu f primed X so
these conditions imply that the
corresponding solution X mu is feasible
in the primal corresponding solution s
muse feasible in the dual moreover their
duality gap X mu X mu s mu is equal to
theta times mu so theta was the degree
of our polynomial and mu was the
parameter but now we can turn it around
and we can say for any pair of primal
point X and you point s we can associate
mu by taking s X and dividing it by by
by theta so this set of unique solutions
excuse me while you define what we call
central path and it's a central object
in interior point methods and so so then
what we can do is we can generate
algorithms where we choose our metric
local metric very carefully and we
somehow loosely or closely follow the
central path so what are the okay so
very little time left with you know all
right
ok so then let me let me define let me
define a function so local metric so
let's say local metric
so so I'm going to define a function for
any given pair of X NS as W plus minus f
prime W X okay so so notice that I
define this if you like fix for all X
and this guy for all s in the dual this
is a nice function and the most non
trivial part we have already seen and
well done which is this one which we
know is convex regardless of how we pick
X NS so this function already appeared
in a proof in a paper of Nesterov and
TOD in the context of South skilled
barriers this is all they show the
existence of a metric a positive
definite metric that map's X 2's and it
comes from a hessian now we can do the
same thing under these assumptions that
I described because this function is
convex this nuptse still convex because
this guy is just linear in W and it's
interesting that this function is well
defined on the whole column not just the
interior but in the algorithm we worked
before we work in the interior so so for
instance let me just give you a theorem
to give you a taste taste of what you
can prove about about this result so for
all so you fix X and s for every x and s
like this for all W and the interior of
the piper ballistic on we have the
following following results so how
should I do it now let me just write the
upper bound first so this guy is upper
bounded by 1 over 2 square root of me
you so let's define U to be SX Oh
or theta like we did so this and then
this this
so this is the function that minimizes
so the minimizer's of this function
minimizer's w bar satisfy f double-prime
w x equals s so you just write the
necessary conditions for optimality use
convexity and you can see that not only
that the Hessian at W Maps the primal
hyperbole stick-on into its dual but
actually it Maps your specific X to
specific s and in the case of what are
called symmetric cones this actually if
the Hessian at W satisfying this
condition gives you the largest pair of
primal dual ellipsoids that are
contained in the respective cones and
that are centered at X NS a theorem of
taught from 2009 so in that sense in
terms of ellipsoidal approximations it
is the best approximation to both primal
and dual feasible region okay so this
and then you know for experts for for
for non experts who saw these local
norms for the first time this may look
magical but I think you can at least
appreciate the simplicity simplicity
it's the local norm of X this is the
local norm of s I am measuring it with
respect to not the Hessian but the
inverse of the Hessian this is the dual
on so everything is happening in terms
of the good good barriers and there is a
lower bound in terms of so that tells
you have the analysis of such an
algorithm might go there is also a lower
bound in terms of same kind of things
and the lower bound is s W star plus XW
star and then this is greater equal to 2
times square root of s w star X W star
and this is greater equal to 2 times
square root of mu so it just gives you
some some beautiful beautiful result
that relates this kind of variational
approach that determine
sort of the best local metric to things
in terms of the local norm defined by
the Hessian at W and you see that there
are similar animals and under some
conditions they are tight some other
conditions they are not so but it just
gives you a flavor of how pub disco
go so let me quickly tell you before I
get the red card I already got the
yellow card I should at least tell you
the algorithm and the special or
goodness okay I have to talk three times
as fast which people who know me know I
can do okay so so the algorithm I'm just
gonna say what it does instead of
writing it algorithm solves minimizes
this and find such a W if you like
approximately and then looks at how
closely the central path equation is
satisfied if this if it's satisfied
close enough it uses this as the metric
to find the surf friction if it is not
it does a rank to update that it's sort
of related to some work that I did in
2001 and then later with a student of
mine maccer boost in 2014 and then that
satisfies the central path equation for
that metric and then it computes the
corresponding corresponding saturation
and the step sizes and the theorem is
that it leads to it leads to many order
of square root of theta log 1 over
epsilon iteration complexity
primal dual algorithms which exploit
exploit negative curvature implied by
hyperbola City so so this is sort of the
general general setup but the the sort
of to me the chakra now part I mean I
love the theoretical part but there's
actually a class of cones that we
identified about a year and a half ago
that are called
homogeneous coral cones special case a
very special case but still strictly
more general than Nestor of Todd
Sycamore Jarrell I'm seeing the red card
so now I have to say what they are
quickly so these are the cones that can
be expressed as a semi definite cone
intersecting the linear subspace where
the sparsity graph does not contain a c4
or p4 as an OD induced minor does not
contain c4 because this coral does not
contain p4 because it has to be
homogeneous so those there is one more
theorem I was going to say but I have
the red card so the theorem there says
that such a metric decomposes into
primal and dual automorphisms
in a way that you can have what's called
the v-space approach for such problems
and when it comes to this being a
second-order method
it works like a first order method
because the Hessians of such barriers
for homogeneous coordinates are very
fast to compute not worse than the
gradient thank you very much
time for questions and discussion of
course different airlines have different
methods for them deciding their status
so let's try something there front so so
if your average number is infinity you
are invited to ask a question you
disconnected from air - in the
collaboration graph awareness to ask the
speaker question my measure of it's
gonna be on the exam
okay and let's try air - number three or
more so if your address number is three
four five something like this you can
ask yourself yes I think it may be too
but I'm gonna just cut in front okay I
have a question so so I listed these
conditions for these barriers and the
thing is that I do not know whether
every convex cone admits a barrier
function like that which has negative
curvature so the most general class of
convex cones which I know then admit
such a barrier or the hyperbole is the
cones and we also have a calculus of
such barriers you can take their sum
which is equivalent to multiplication of
the underlying underlying hamaji
hyperbolic polynomials we can take
restrictions to linear subspaces again a
familiar algebraic thing and we can take
linear preimages and direct sums
obviously so that's that's a question
that I have I don't know if the class of
convex cones which admit such barrier
functions is more general than the
hyperbola cones
so if you have Irish number where they
equal three and you're not the speaker
[Music]
perspective so how did what access for
people you need very good so so the
question is what kind of input format do
you need for P to actually run such an
algorithm so so we really need to
evaluate the polynomial and we need to
evaluate its gradient at least so with
that with that I can do so now if you're
writing your code in fact we have some
code hopefully at some point there will
be three codes or so I'm hoping for for
these things in one of the codes what we
have is straight line programs so if you
enter your polynomial is a straight line
program that's the circuit you just tell
me you know in order what operations I
need to do then that's sufficient to run
this thing and if as a result for your
polynomial if you have a straight line
program that runs in polynomial time in
some say parameter that you picked as a
graph or whatever the real input is then
this this algorithm will run in
polynomial time to produce an
approximately optimal solution but
another thing I need is this e I need
this interior point in the in the in the
interior of the hyperbola stick on but
straight line programs currently sort of
the most common way so what I would do
is I would have an input setup where it
is a determinantal function or it's this
straight given as a straight line
program so those are the sort of minimal
requirements that even in practice it
works okay so very good question is how
about computing the roots well of course
I didn't even get into doing the line
search and stuff like this so there is a
beautiful theory if you allow me short
steps and if I do that very enough I can
actually award computing roots you know
because I know from these theories that
certain convex sets are included in my
cone and so on but of course in
practical algorithm we'll have to
compute routes to relatively decent
accuracy and it's sort of straight-line
programs we can we can do that okay
everybody so even if you're others
number is 102 or if you are a brush or
if you're Elvis very good so your
question is so good I already maybe have
more but in any case the question is how
do you can you say that it's you know I
said determinants to representation or
or a straight line program clearly if
you give me a determinant and uses it
correctly in this hyperbolic that's okay
that's why Pablo says well what if
somebody gave you a straight line
program for a polynomial and it's not
hyperbolic so I guess I should have made
that clear then I don't know the
algorithm would potentially fail so I
wouldn't I would need the users exactly
exactly exactly so that's a very kind
kind remark so public saying that so
that I am saying that as long as the
user correctly verified and takes full
responsibility for their polynomial for
being hyperbolic the algorithm will run
correctly but of course you know they
gave me an e there's nothing in what's
the con then it will of course fail but
those aren't both kinds of users yes yes
that's a very good point so remark Pablo
is making is that well you can randomly
generate a straight line program for a
class of polynomials manages any way you
want in terms of depth and variation in
the operations that you use and then
just experiment and one of them some of
them might not even be hyperbolic they
might not even define a convex set but
at the end you might actually solve the
problem I like and the thing is that
they might be hyperbolic it might even
be np-hard or Co np-hard to certify that
they are but but the algorithm might run
nice okay yes so what's the advantage of
the negative culture over
self-importance IQ this iteration
complexity you can also get read
short-staffed that's right in fact the
cleanest analysis the shortest analysis
somehow uses uses the minimizer of this
function and then does this rank to
update and bounce the bounds of operator
norm of the rank to update based on this
this big operator norm and that's very
clean but-but-but-but that algorithm
actually really generates things inside
the Dakini ellipsoid it really finds the
optimal solution with an ellipsoid it
typically takes a corrector step in the
next iteration to get close to the
central path or that it mixes the what
we called affine scaling direction with
the centering direction but it stays
quite close to the central path but but
the advantage of this this negative
curvature is that the hessian the change
in the hessian can be managed in this
big ball which is essentially the
largest nice approximation you can have
to your set so so in that sense you can
actually take pretty large steps in the
primal the the hyperbolic secant problem
now the issue is that as i said we don't
know as much about the dual con and as a
result in these algorithms you don't
want to enforce complete primal dual
symmetry all you want to use do is use
the dual information' so in that sense
you know I didn't even define the legend
referential conjugate of F in sometimes
I don't need it because I know that F
prime provides a by ejection between the
interior of this and int arrow the dual
con and I can do things in terms of just
F prime and that's the right way to do
it so so it's so in that sense there are
the way that we update the primal which
is based on this big convex set and the
way that we update the dual are
different so in that sense the inside of
the algorithm is not symmetric primal
dual but I call this primal dual
symmetric algorithms because the
algorithm is sophisticated enough that
it applies all it knows and on the
easier problem as a result if you were
to try to fool the algorithm by giving
your primal corners
this the algorithm would still solve
what's called a hyperbolic heavy in
hyperbolic heavyweight so there is a
there is a there is an advantage okay so
I suggest we thank the speaker for Jim
Raynor gosh there's now actually a
breath